kann man die werden wir schon direkt
angezeigt das heißt drauf und im besten
fall direkt connected home power 360 hey
leute was gehabt und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja ja ich hoffe
natürlich jedes gut heute nach langer 2
oder was heißt langer zeit also es geht
wieder los mit einem richtigen haupt
video auch juli ist wieder dabei wo
wasser urlaub wie oft hast du diesen
urlaub gemacht
der gut ich war bei meinen eltern das
theater nicht auf jeden fall kam ja
letzte woche ein video da habe ich
airports von tedi getestet also sodinger
die halt bei tedi angeboten wurde
dieses case solche ausmachen weil dort
ein klick und die airports sind größer
als mein finger eine war irgendwie total
neu im trend und ich hab euch daraufhin
auf winzerin gefragt ob instagram heißt
alex wie könnte ich mir sehr gerne
folgen
ob ihr denn noch in irgendeinem laden
sei es jetzt action kik takko aldi wo
auch immer so eine art airport kopie
gesehen habt und ich habe daraufhin sehr
viele tipps bekommen und habe jetzt auch
welche gefunden und zwar einmal bei kik
und bei real und bei tk maxx das sind
alles unterschiedliche modelle die von
tk maxx ähneln denen sehr stark der rest
ist so geht so also dem original halt
und heute fangen wir an mit pick also
praktisch so bluetooth kopfhörer in
anführungsstrichen airports von kik für
10 eur 990 gekostet und ja ich hole die
macht hier wollte ich auch alles richtig
kakao gezogen hier haben wir einmal die
von kik also das habe ich gedacht okay
bluetooth kopfhörer sieht mir irgendwie
nach kabel aus aber wir werden sehen ob
und bei tk maxx meine so eine
verkäuferin hier
das haben wir auch von airports und das
ist halt einfach nur seine hülle und ich
hätte es nicht mehr gekürzt
naja gut setzen was verhindert eine
sache die ich nämlich noch sagen wollte
beim tee die video die airports das
waren die das waren die sieben tws
dieses modell gibt es im internet für
vier euro und ich habe es halt bei ti
für 15 gekauft und bei müller gibt es
das wohl auch noch für halt dich fest 30
frechheit naja diese hier habe ich
allerdings ausschließlich bei kik
gefunden und ich bin einfach mal
gespannt
ich bin richtig gespannt auf die mich
überzeugen heute geht es natürlich in
erster linie um die soundqualität wir
haben hier auch natürlich mikrofon dabei
zehn meter empfangs reichweite wir
machen immer wieder die dümmste fraktion
die kommentaren fragen auf einer weiß
warum ist diese verpackungen gibt ich
verstehe das wissen aber ich alle heute
auch schon gefragt weiß dass seine leute
wenn ihr wissen dass solche scheiß
verpackung wird schreibt es mal gerne in
die kommentare
was hat das denn mit bluetooth zu tun
und folter erzwungen weil ich kann da
irgendwie nicht so gut aus bringen das
heißt arrangements
ich hab' ich weiß das glaube ich dass du
scheiße naja sie das gut aus nein weil
wir jetzt tun wir so als würde ich das
zocken benutzen
also wer denkt sich denn sowas aus da
kann man hier auch gleich mit kabeln
nehmen weil das dumme ist ja wenn du
damit geht das wackelt erfolg verhilft
nochmals kwh und wenn nur ein kabel dran
hast das sieht es ja wenigstens nach
unten das ist nicht wackeln mit na ja
gut ich will jetzt gar nicht direkt
sagen das ist scheiße ist vielleicht ist
ja die soundqualität brutal und so wer
weiß aber auch allein schon gibt dir das
mal hier
also ich muss sagen ich habe den
nirgendwo anders im internet gefunden
aber zehn euro dafür ist für mich schon
wieder mit recht
naja haben wir hier noch irgendwas bei
der beschreibung und und klar wird dass
327 usb-kabel dass wir wieder zu viel
wir versuchen das erst mal so zu
connecten also hier haben wir ja den
startknopf
ich mache ich drücke mal drauf kommen
die bringen ja alle modelle so rot und
blau de na ja das gute ist wir müssen
jetzt hier nicht wieder versuchen die
einzelnen kopfhörer zu verbinden so
hatten wir letztes mal das problem das
hat echt lange gedauert weil die sind ja
per kabel verbunden da gehe ich auch mal
davon aus dass das ohne probleme geht so
dann gehen wir jetzt mal hier
einstellungen bluetooth kommen warum
kommen die werden wir schon direkt
angezeigt das heißt und im besten fall
direkt connected home power 360 ja- und
rein damit ins ohr ich mache erst kurz
im test sondern kommt wieder juni
ok also muss ich immer da war ihm durch
einen musiker und dj bist du hast doch
du kannst dich doch da besser aus als
ich sagte ja ist ja auch so ist aber ich
sage auch wo habe ich dann gesagt ist
gut bei den e 200 bis jetzt die wahl in
ordnung
5000 blick da ja nicht mehr du auch ich
habe da mittlerweile richtig immer
termine aus was machen wir heute an
vermieter was neues aus modus mio was
nach kamera honda civic kommt noch was
soziales oder was ist dann alles ja
rendite oder galas 44 bonbon das klingt
super
erstmals weist anfängt morgen wagen
bauen bauen bauen
[Musik]
ich sage mal erst mal nix für irgendwann
einmal wenn du jetzt vielleicht die
musik drin hast dann sage ich meine
meinung zu den leuten dazu ok und dann
gucken wir was du dazu sagt okay leute
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wie man
das hören soll
du kriegst kopfschmerzen nach zehn
minuten du hast brutale kopfschmerzen
das ist ja man so eine katastrophe also
das ist wegen einer voll katastrophe
dieses körperverletzung
was sagst du im letzten video unter
letzten video habe ich oft kommentar
gelesen und man muss auch sagen das
letzte video hat fast 100 discs weil
leute geschrieben haben wir machen uns
über die lustig über die kopfhörer
aber es also ist halt nur da kann man
sich auch nur darüber lustig machen
das sind jetzt von allen geschlechtes
noda hatten wir schon mal so was
schlecht ist und hier ist sogar noch ein
scheiß kabel dran
es gibt halt airports die besseren sound
machen und günstiger ja ja klar
wie alle leute die sowas kaufen wir
haben doch den reichweitentest und den
mikrofon test okay der war vom sound her
ist das echt einfach nur wie keine
ahnung mithalten was packe es gibt kein
bass wird wenig vorhanden die hochschule
und die mittel töne hören sich an wie
plastik und das war es einfach kein
schöner ton jedes handy hat den besseren
sound als diese kopfhörer okay na ja gut
ich mache mir noch mal kurz die musik an
und ich gehe mal immer weg weil ich
stand ja zehn meter reichweite und von
da bis dahin ist ja zehn meter
manchmal viel zu weit ich gehen mit dem
handy weiter weg ja also die kommunen
steht ist ja ich komme mächtig lauten
sound
hast du schon mal jemanden gesehen der
bahn ist sowas vielleicht zu 60 jährige
die sich wichtig fühlen ich hoffe die
machen jetzt anfangen
hallo ja klingt schon müll ja man kann
es verstehen aber es ist nicht so schön
manchmal ist die bluetooth-verbindung
russland ist nun redet man normal ja
viel besser geht weiter
ja ist auf jeden fall viel deutlich mehr
weil ich war noch mal normal sagt man
irgendwie den gleichen satz normal mit
kopf und einmal ohne zuschüsse wenn man
es mit dem kopfhörer ich hab es dann
irgendwann selbst nicht mehr gehört auch
jetzt weitermachen mit der gruppe a gut
was wirst du dazu noch sagen soll ich
die kopfhörer trotzdem noch mal ins all
around verlosen eigentlich schon ne also
leute wenn ihr dieses meisterwerk haben
wollt schickt einfach meinen insider
marktpreis ich alex w ich poste dass
seine story muss einfach auch die story
antworten will haben oder so und dann
wird immer nach 34 tagen jemand
ermittelt und den krieg ich die zu ganz
einfach ansonsten haben ihr noch
irgendwas zu sagen das war jetzt der
wievielte airport er protest zum 100
der benutzte mal gucken die finger noch
kommt natürlich muss man jetzt sagen das
kommt sehr wenig an der airport
kopierern aber so drei jahre auf eurem
hinweis und man kann ja so was dann auch
mal testen ob die soundqualität hier
vielleicht leisten wenn ihr in welchen
läden auch immer airport fakes lädt die
es nicht im internet gibt oder so
schreibt mir dass ich taste die gerne
ich kaufe die und dann machen wir video
dazu wir sehen uns morgen 19 uhr wieder
gibt es ein neues video und sonst was
das haut rein obwohl in den kanal glocke
aktivieren
und doch zog